智慧の生き方というテーマの第二番目
智慧について この前の勉強会でいくらかは説明しました
その場合は区別したのは知識と智慧ということ
その区別がありますと
知識っていうのは勉強している概念の集まりなんですね
で 例えば英語を勉強すると言うと
英語の知識が増えるんですね
そこで単語というような
いろいろ音を覚えておいて
その音に日本語ではどういう意味しますかと
そこを覚えて 頭の中でちゃんと溜まっておくんです
そうすると英語の知識があるということ
そちらにもいくらか智慧というものがあります
じゃあ英語を勉強してたんだからといって自由自在に使えるか
自由自在に使えるかという問題があるわけです
そこで 自分の頭の中で溜まったこの知識
概念を適当に その場でその場で必要な概念綺麗に並んでさっさっさっと使えるならば
そちらに特別に特別な能力
そこに見えるんです そこら辺はなんとなく智慧の働き
だから勉強した英語を忘れないように
ずっと大事に守っておこうと思うと
それはいくらか労働力かかります
いわゆる頭働くことも一つの私は労働だと
レーベルだと思っているんですね
体だけじゃないんです
でも自分知ってる単語はまあ例えばまあ 一万個ぐらいの言葉かもしれません
あるいは五千ぐらいの言葉かもしれません
そこはすごく自由にスムースに使用できるんだ
その場で その場という能力はまあどうしようもない能力で
先生にはそれを教えられて教えられることはできません
ですから この智慧と知識の働きというのは普通人間にはあるんですね
そこでどちらが役に立ちますかというと
智慧の方が役に立ちます
知識の方は試験合格ぐらいなんですね
全部覚えていて 忘れないようにして
試験で全部出して終わっちゃうんですね
ですから 知識だけだと思うならば
まあ試験もギリギリまで待っていて
できるだけ何とか何とかして覚えてさっさっさっといて答えて
もうそれで入れて忘れちゃえばいいんです
でも 一生我々の役に立つのはそれではなくて違うものなんです
そこでこの自由に 例えば英語の単語を使えるという場合は
それは別に苦しくもないし
何のことない すごく楽々なんですね
ですから 知識の方が労働力で
智慧の方がすごい楽と
役に立つのは一生自分のためになるのは知識ではなくて智慧の方なんです
ですから  なんか知識の使い方の一つ智慧なんですね
我々の知識と経験とかいろいろありますから
それはどのように使ってますかと
使用していますか？と
生きるために役に立ってますか？というのは智慧の世界
それであるならば 仏教は智慧の世界
いつでも大変大事な一番高い道徳
最高な道徳は智慧であります
他のものじゃないんです
全部他の道徳っていうのは相対的で
その場でその場で道徳であって
そのある時は道徳でない場合もあります
例えば叱るなということは叱ってはいけません
人を叱ってはね いけませんでしょ
それは道徳なんです でもだからといってずっと絶対的に人を叱ってはいけませんかと
それはそこ問題なんですね
やっぱり叱った方が叱らないよりはよろしいんじゃないかという場合もあります
ですから この 道徳の世界ではもうかなりの量が相対的なんですね
知恵っていうのはそういうものではないんです
我々の幸福のために 安らかにというか
ね まあ平安で幸福でいられるために必要な技ですから
そこにはまあ相対的なものではない絶対的な道徳なんですね
ですから 仏教ではこの真理と道徳を両方語ってますけど
結局仏教というのは最高たる真理
発見することは知恵であって
それ自体が道徳のまあ終着駅でもあります
終わりでもあります ですから
知恵っていうのは大変大事に考えなくてはいけない
そこで知恵というものは人生に役に立つもの
我々の問題 生きる上で現れてくる一切の問題
解決してくれるもの 幸福を作ってくれる
幸福になれるものであって
苦をなくすものだから
人は知恵の方を目指すべきなんですね
そういうわけで 仏教は知恵の話にはなっています
まあだからといって知識は否定していますかというと
それは否定してないんです
知識も知恵の役に立つならば
知識も得た方がよろしい
それから仏教では勉強は 2つに分けてますね
あの こういう勉強するものと
それからこのテクノロジー
現代の言葉で言えば お釈迦様の時代ではテクノロジーという言葉はなかったんだけど
で でも似ている言葉がありますね
勉強することはバーブサッチャと言って
このバフッスタという言葉でよく聞いた
聞いたことがあるという意味なんです
いわゆる勉強っていうのは
昔は聞いて覚えるものだから
ですから今も我々は聞いて見て
頭の中で覚えておくもの
それは勉強で それから体で習うものは
昔のパーリ語でシッッタと言うんですね
まあローマ字で言うならば SIPPA
サンスクリット語だったらシルパと言うんですね
SILPA の上にちょっと点入れないと
まあそんなことは今日のテーマではないんだから
別にどうったことないんだけど
シッッタというのはパーリ語
シルッパというのはサンスクリット語
それはまあ 私たちの現代の言葉で言うならば
これテクノロジーのことなんですね
そこで学問が 2つに分けてあって
そういう風にちゃんと知識的に勉強するものと
テクノロジーというもの
その両方はまあよく頑張ってやりなさいと
とは言っているんです
その 2つの あの2つ あの
これは 1つテクノロジーだけなんですけど
勉強と学問とテクノロジーという
この両方人間にあってほしいんだと
でもそれは何のためかというと
やっぱり幸せで生きているためなんですね
だから勉強することは一生懸命したんだけど
いろんな技術も身についたんだけど
全く役に立たないというならば
それはまた意味がないんですね
何の意味もないんです
ですから 私たちは小さい時からも
何か勉強するとき 何か技術を自分が習う時
それは自分の幸福に 人類の幸福になるものかということを考えた方が
これ私の役に立ちますかと
あるいは人の役に立ちますかということも考えた方がいいと思います
そう考えると 我々はくだらない勉強いっぱいやってるんじゃないかな
くだらない技術をね 何の役にも立たない
ただ威張るだけの技術
どうだいとみんなに見せっこするだけの技術もいっぱいやってると思いますけどね
ですから 知恵の世界を中心にして考えると
私たちは今やっているほとんどの無駄な努力というのはかなりなくなって
かなり楽になりますなんて
それだけででも かなり楽になるんですね
そうするといろいろ時間の余裕も生まれてくるんですね
その時間の余裕が生まれてきたら
さらに真理を探求するために
それを使った方がよろしいです
ですから今日は今日の話はこの
この講演が講義だから
あのこの具体的に実践的にこの喋るということは
いつでも私にとってはやりたくないことでやってはいけないことです
で 具体的な例というのは
たった一つのケースで一つの答えだけであって
普遍性はないんです ですから
もし今日何かこれから一生知恵の人間で生きているために
何か方程式とか何か教えてくれるだろうと思っているかもしれませんだけど
それはちょっと甘い話です
そうすると何かあ こういう風に生きてますよ
何か一つ決めつけたら
それだけで知恵がなくなっちゃうんです
ですから その知恵っていうのは自分で発見するものであって
人から教えてもらうものではないんです
この間 自分のある友達何人かと話してた時は
一人がいきなり仏教の話を聞きたくていろいろ質問したんだけど
その人  knowledge と wisdom という 2つを定義するんですね
で 彼が言うには knowledge is transferable knowledge
というものは 知識というものは人に与えることはできますと wisdom
というのは知恵のこと
それは人に与える あげることはできません
でも両方必要ですよ だから彼がところで
もう一人友達がもうそれどういうことか説明してくれ
はっきりと言ったら 彼が科学の分野で大学の教授なんですけど
彼が言うのは 例えば自分の父親
全然勉強したことがないんだと
ただの田舎のおじいさんだと
何の学問も何もないんだと
でも私にとっては なんか父親と喋ると
なんかすごく あの 不思議でしょうがないんだと
自分がもうものすごい勉強して
もう今外国の大学で教授になって仕事をしているんだけど
自分の国の田舎でもう普通の生活をしている父親といまだに喋ったってのなんか何か違うんだと
なんか自分の過ちやらいろんなことを直してあげたり
これはこうではないか
ああではないかと いろいろ能力を持ってるんですね
そこで彼が言うのは 自分の父親は knowledge はないんだけど
wisdom はあるんだと
で 私もその話を聞いて
まあやっぱりまあ彼が言うことには意味がいくらかあるんですね
いわゆるこの生きる技なんですね
いろんな問題に出会うことは我々の生き方なんですね
何も問題ないということは人生ではないんです
生きるということは 毎日毎日何か問題に出会うこと
その問題を解決して乗り越えていくということには
生きるということを言うんです
問題に出会ったところで乗り越えられない場合は
その人にはそれ以上は生きていられません
で 例で言うならば 例えば学校でいじめられたと
そのいじめられた子がその問題は乗り越えられない場合は
それ以上は生きていられませんね
それで人生そこで終わってしまっちゃうんです
我々は嫌になるほど年取って生きているということは
まあなんだかんだもいろいろ問題はなんとかなんとかしてきたんだから
だから生きるということ自体にもいくらか知恵の働きがあるんです
そういうわけで我々よく言うでしょ？人生の経験があるんだと
昔から言ってるでしょうね
年上の人の話は聞きなさい
経験豊かな人々の話を聞きなさい
で その人々はやっぱりいくらか知恵を持ってるんです
[背景の騒音]ですから
この生きるということはまあ死んでないということだから
毎日問題に出会うでしょう
確かに その出会う問題
何とかして乗り越える
それで元気で生きていられるわけですね
それで私たちはどんな問題も解決するわけじゃないんです
生きる場合は 時々問題はあるんだけど
どうしても自分がそれは立ち触りたくない
解決できない だからって自殺するわけでもないんです
それで解決できないいろんな問題にぶつかると
人々の人生はどんどん暗くなっちゃうんです
その人間に何で精神的なストレス
悩み 苦しみがあるかというと
この毎日自分が立ち向かういろんな問題を乗り越えていくことはできない時でしょ
はっきりそれわかりやすいことなんです
ですから ただ単に馬鹿みたく長生きしたっても
人生は暗いんだったら
悲観的であるならば 元気じゃないならば
明るくて活発的でないならば
その人にはあまり知恵というものは
身についてないんです
ですから 私の前の言った
もうちょっと先に言った言葉はちょっと訂正しなくちゃいけない
先に言ったのは もう長生きする人々はそれなりに知恵があったんだから長生きしているのではないかと
だから年上の人の話を聞きなさいと
でもそれも絶対的な言葉ではないんです
我々より年上で経験豊かで
なおかつすごい元気で
明るくて エネルギッシュで
まあ怖いものは知らないと
というすごい明るく活発的な人に限るんです
何か教えてくださいと
暗くて悲観的で もう精神的にものすごく弱くて
もう隠れ隠れ人生している人々にとっては
人から指導を受けない方が
我々受けない方がよろしいんですね
だからそこでその明確に区別わかるだろうと思います
だから知恵の定義はしっかりしているんです
知恵っていうのは必ずしも幸福というもの
安らぎというもの あるいは自信というものをつけてくれるんです
そこで生きるということは
はっきりと問題が毎日毎日
毎分毎分毎分何か問題がある
それを乗り越える それを乗り越えるということは生きるということなんです
それをちゃんと理解してほしい
その毎分毎分ごとに我々が出会う問題をもう解決して解決しているんです
その問題解決すること自体は人生なんですね
よく覚えておいてください
この世の中で他の定義もあります
人生って何ですかと言えば
ですから この定義はなんとなく
あの ものすごい派手に聞こえないんだからといって
あまり無視するんではなくて
ちゃんと覚えておいてください
自分の人生の役に立ちます
私にはこれは言う自信もあります
これはぴったしした定義だと
人生って何ですかと というと
私はしっかりしたもう完全たる定義は
もう毎分でもいいし 毎秒でもいいし
一時間ごとでも 時間はあまり関係ないんだけど
あるいは仏教的では瞬間瞬間なんですけど
まあ瞬間瞬間 我々は何かを何か問題にぶつかる
アプローチする そこをなんとか乗り越える
それ終わったら次の 中で
捨てるではない 幸せに生きているわけです
そこで 例えば百個の問題に出会ったところで
やっと十個ぐらいは解決できたというような場合や
二十個ぐらい解決できたという人が暗くて悲観的で
いろんな問題トラブル起こしちゃうんですね
[背景の騒音]そこで論理的でない人々はこの仏教の話でも他の宗教の話でも宗教でも聞いて
このトラブルない人生探すんです
今日電車で宣伝を見たところで
あの家庭安全 商売繁盛
それから開運 もう一つあった
あ？何ですか？あ そうそうそう
それやって次にその他もあります
またその他 だからまあそれから言ったらね
失礼だから次の だからここらに行って
お祈りしましょう 初詣はここらでやってください
で その宣伝している場所も日本ですごい有名な
で そちらにはまあお金なんかは雨が降るような感じで降ってくれるところなんですね
だから 行く人々にとってはどうかとわかりませんだけどね
そういうのは理性的な生き方
考え方ではないんです
それはもう怠け者の生き方で
ずるい生き方で ずるいやり方で開運幸福を開いてもようではないかと
それはずるい生き方なんです
だからゲームではズルくしてはいけませんでしょうに
私は一つのゲームだとも言ってますからね
生きることは ゲームやるんだったら堂々正々堂々とやらなくちゃいけないんです
そこでズルくやっちゃうと
じゃあ宝出てそうなるんですかね
ならないんでしょ 結局はそうなるんだったら
人類は全然頑張る必要はないしね
お祈りだけすればいいでしょうに
ですから そういう論理的でないところもあります
なぜそういう例を出したんですかというと
こうやってこの完全たる安全な境地
この生きている間は問題ない世界
商売はしているんだけど
ただ繁盛するだけと儲かるだけと
そういうことを思ったら
ものすごい危険で無知で
知恵の全く逆な世界 無知な世界なんです
そこで私たち仏教というのは
そういう考え方はあまりにも屁理屈だから
あまりにも非科学的だから
そんなことはいい加減やめましょう
商売会社なんか作ったら
損することも得することもいろいろ変化するんです
これ五分五分とも言えないし
五分五分だったら商売になりませんから
その変化するんですよ
時々六十パーセント損する場合もあるし
時々六十パーセント得する場合もあるし
だから毎日問題なんです
毎日問題なんです 例えば幸せに生きていきたいんだから
じゃあ結婚してみましょうと
冗談じゃない 結婚したんだからって
完全たる幸せな生き方
そんなこの頭の妄想概念しかなんもないんです
結婚するということ自体も問題
それからの毎日毎日新しい問題があるはずなんです
そこで知恵の生き方っていうのは
この毎日毎日私が出会うそのその問題はどのように解決するかっていうことなんです
解決するか逃げるか 解決するか逃げるか
どっちでしょう だから逃げる人々は幸福をつかめません
自信がなくて 怖くて 言い訳をして問題から逃げるならば
その人の人生は暗い そこで堂々と問題をちゃんと自分で解決するならば
その人の人生は明るい
時々私も聞いたことありますけど
この私なんかこんな宗教とかなんてこと考えたこともない
で そこで私は宗教を教えてる人だから
まあひどい人やと思ったりはしません
なぜかというと そんなこと考えるにも名前
この人 自分の毎日の問題に立ち向かって全部解決していくんですね
だから結局自信があって明るいんですね
だから別に私がそこにいて余計なお世話する必要はないんです
お説教する必要はないんです
そうですね それは良かったっていうこと
反応しかないんです ですから
生きるということは そういうふうによく覚えておいて
毎日問題はあると それすごい厳密に考えると
やっぱり瞬間瞬間 私たちは何かやらなくちゃいかないということがいつでもあるんです
そのやらなくちゃいかないことをやらないと
そこで問題起こるんです
例えば歯磨くことでも同じことでしょうに
そこは問題なんです 何もしないでいると歯が汚れちゃいますね
それで磨かなくちゃいけないんです
もしそれは怠けてやらなかったならば
ものすごい大変な問題を本人が作るでしょうに
それによって自分の人生不幸になるでしょうに
歯が悪くなったり 虫歯になったりとか
それに関連してありったけのいろんな病気が移ったりしちゃうと
それだけでも自分の人生は不幸になってしまうんですね
だから寝床が冷たいんだからといってね
まあ今日は寒いんだから
なんか起きたくはないんだとかね
洗面所の方がすごく冷えているんだから
まあそっちは行きたくないと
まあ明日にするぞとか
そうやって今やらなくちゃいかない問題を解決しないで逃げる人が当たり前
不幸になってしまうんですね
食べる場合も 体に必要な量を
必要な栄養などをバランスをとって食べなくちゃいかない
それで怠けて 私みたいに毎日同じものを食べると
まあどこかでトラブルが起こるんですね
ですから 智慧の生き方としてお釈迦様が言うのは元気で頑張りなさいと
たったそれだけなんです
怠けるな 暗くならないで
問題一つ一つ解決していけばいいんです
この解決できない人々には智慧がないことは確かでしょうし
それで暗くなるでしょうし
それでずるいことを考えちゃうんです
ゲームで負けるとずるいことを考えるでしょ
で 日本であるかどうかわかりませんだけど
テレビなんかで見られますから
カジノ キャシノとかね
いろんなそういうところでも危なくて行けないほどのところなんですね
なぜか そういうところで必ず勝つ人も負ける人も両方いますから
それで負ける人々がなんとか犯罪でも起こしたりする
で 私がいるところで駅のそばにパチンコ屋さんがいるんです
そちらに看板書いてあります
外国人を断る だから行けないんです
外国人大歓迎ってついていたっても行けませんだけど
だからお断りと書いてるんだから
なんとなく行って一言は言ってやろうかなと気持ちは思われる
あれ読むたびに まあそれで覚えてるんだけど
そこでなんでそこで外国人を断りとか言ってるのは
別にそこは外国人差別してるとか何とかではなくて
日本で不法滞在とかいろいろことをやって
いろんな何か出稼ぎとかいろんな目的で来ていて
で 普通の仕事をして それなりにいくらかお金を儲けて生活するということで負けると
あるいは日本にはもう何て言いますか
不法入国したにしたっても
そこであちらでは仕事はないとかね
それ自分にはすごい問題があるんですね
それでずるい 何かずるいことでもして
で 何人か名前言ったら
それも差別ということになりますから
このすべての外国人ではなくて
ある一つの国の外国人がそこら辺で頭がすぐ働いて
このパチンコ機械っていうのはね
いろいろ操ってかなりお金が入るようにしているんだと
だからそこら辺でなんでそういう人々はずるいことをしますかというと
自分が立ち向かっている問題に堂々正々堂々と
戦わないんですね それでずるいことをするんです
ですから 世の中でなぜ犯罪あるかというと
この智慧がないんだからなんです
なぜ汚職しますかと なぜ賄賂取るんですか？だから我々生きている世界はすごい綺麗なんです
色鮮やかです いろんな
まあ汚職ですから いろんな形のことをやってるんですね
だから人間の社会 ソサエティというものを見ると
何か変なことを 誰であろうと何かやってるんですね
だからそこで何か見えますか？その人々は
やっぱり自分毎日 毎週
瞬間瞬間立ち向かう問題をきちんと解決しない
きちんと乗り越えようとしない
あるいは乗り越えない
それでずるいことをする
だから 知恵の人間が現れてくると
世の中で犯罪もないんです
正々堂々できてるんだから
法律すら要らなくなっちゃうんです
そういうわけで 最高たる道徳は智慧になってしまうんです
そこで次のポイントってじゃなくて
その同じポイントのもうちょっとなんですが
で まあ私たちにこの毎日毎日我々は
この立ち向かわなくちゃいけない問題じゃ毎日毎日解決していくことをできればもう最高な幸せなんですけど
問題はそれできないことでしょ
どんな問題もきちんと解決するぞと
ということはできないことは問題なんですよ
だから言ってる理屈はわかるでしょ
どなた様でも 言ってる理屈はわかりますけど
でも実際に私たちは毎日出会わなくちゃいけない
この 出会うと言うんですよ
コンファンテーション
その 毎日そういう立ち向かわなくちゃいかない
その問題解決できない場合はどうしますか？と
例えばお腹が空いた 何か食べなくちゃいけない
それぐらいは誰にもできます
歯が汚れた だから磨かなくちゃいけないと
それも解決はできるでしょうね
おそらく で 服は汚れたんだと
じゃあ洗わなく 洗濯しなくちゃいけないんだと
なんか寒くなってきたんだと
じゃあもう一枚着ようとかね
それぐらいの問題は解決できます
でも時々解決できない問題も出てきます
そこで大変な問題が起こる
そこで精神的な苦しみ
悩みが生まれてくる そこでずるいことをして
まあお守りでも買ってもらって
これ何とかしてくれないかと
神様にでも仏様にでもすがってみようかなとか思ったりする
だからすがる気持ちがある限りは智慧の人生じゃないんです
だから 誰でもすがると思ってはいけません
教えてもらうこととすがることはまた違うんです
だから お釈迦様から教えてもらうのはいいんだけど
全部お釈迦様が守ってくれると思ったら
それは仏教じゃないです
お釈迦様は全部やってくれるんだ
あるいは観音様 仏様 大日如来さんとか阿弥陀如来仏陀さんとかね
やってくれるんだと 思ったらそこは仏教でもなくなっちゃうし
智慧の人生でもなくなっちゃうんです
そこでやり方がわからないと
残念ですけど 仏陀さんは教えてくれません
大日如来様も何も教えてくれない
教えてくれるのは唯一お釈迦様だけなんですね
仏教の世界ではね ですから
お釈迦様はどのように我々に教えているかというところを勉強するのはいいんだけど
だからこの大日如来さんの代わりと代わりとして
あるいは阿弥陀様 皆様今まで例えば日本の方々だから日本仏教
もしかすると信仰していらっしゃったかもしれません
そちらの代わりとして
新しいバージョンとして
今流行っているものとして
何かこの服を着替えるような感じで
じゃあ今度は上座仏教にお釈迦様にしますとかね
気持ち悪いんです  [笑い]あるいは今までキリスト教の神様を信仰していたんだと
そこで仏教の話を聞いて
ああ これいいやと思って
じゃあそれやめてこれにしますと
これ活動にするかもう
そんな感じではダメなんです
だからお釈迦様はそういう
あの 一つ  そういう代わり教えてるわけではなくて
答えを教えてるんですね
智慧は最高たる道徳である
人間は何を目指すべきかというと
智慧を目指すべき 最高たる財産は何ですか？とお釈迦様に聞いたところで
いとも簡単にパンニャーナラーナンワタナン
智慧は人間の最高たる財産で宝物であると
だからすごいしっかり教えてるんです
ある時はお釈迦様こう言うんです
如来の教えは智慧に基づいて智慧を目指して智慧のことを喋ってるんだと
お釈迦様の言葉では全て智慧という一言葉に全部まとめているんだと
すごい力入れてるんですね
このパンニャーという言葉には
だから私たちは瞬間瞬間
何かを問題に立ち向かう
その問題を乗り越えて乗り越えていかなくちゃいけない
乗り越えれば乗り越えるほど
人生は幸福になる 楽しくなる
だからといって問題消えてくれるということではありません
問題消えちゃったらやることはなくなっちゃって
生きることは消えちゃうでしょ
なぜならば生きるということは問題を乗り越えることだから
大変なことになるんです
死ななくちゃいけないんです
その前に あのいじめられてるんだからといって自殺する子供と同じ羽目になっちゃうんです
学校でいじめられて 自分で乗り越えられない弱い子が自殺するでしょう
そこで大人になったところで
まあ自分には何の問題もなくなったと
解決するべきその人をその瞬間で自殺しなくちゃいけないんです
もう生きること終わっちゃったんだから
そんなことはありえないんです
たとえすべての問題解決したとおっしゃっているお釈迦様にしても
お腹が空くでしょうし
そうすると托鉢に出かけるんです
それで体が汚れちゃうんです
それであの 水浴びをする
そこであなたは真理を知ってるでしょ
教えてくださいって言ったら
お釈迦様には問題が起こる
大勢の人々が集めているんだから
逃げるわけにはいきませんね
じゃあ逃げよう それで説法しなくちゃいけないという問題が出てくる
次に説法するのはいいんだけど
一人も理解してくれない
それでこの連中にはどのように喋れば
どんな工夫すれば 目が覚めてくる
目が覚めるかということも考えなくちゃいけなくなってくる
だからお釈迦様にしても
涅槃に入る瞬間まで問題はあったんです
でもお釈迦様は人生は大変だ
自分にとってはね そうは言ってない
私はもう問題は解決しているんだ
心は平安だ 求めるものは何もないんだ
どうしてかというと もう智慧は発見しましたから
智慧の生き方なさっていたんです
だから解決できない問題一つもなかったんです
ただそれだけ 誰であろうとも解決できない問題
ああ困ったなとか どうしようかということは一つもなかったんです
だから私たちのメッセージも同じことで
問題は何にもない あの宣伝広告であったような人生を作るんじゃなくて
商売繁盛からもう家庭安全からね
何から何までその他とあって
そういう境地を作るんじゃなくて
人に能力を与えてあげるんですね
智慧という 解決してみなさい
という話はまた説明してないんですね
言いたかったポイントは
だからこの解決できない問題の場合はどうしますか
[笑い]その場合でしょう
人々は暗くなるのは 問題がある
解決できない自分には
それで暗くなる その瞬間で人生負ける
それで悔しくなる だから悩み苦しみがそこで生まれていきます
そこでお祈りするなりに祈祷やら呪文やらやるなりにいろんなことをやったりもする
犯罪を起こすわ あるいは自殺でもするわ
どっちかと 喧嘩したりする
解決できない場合はどうすればいいんですかね
で わかりやすく言います
私たちには死の瞬間まで解決できない問題一つもないです
一つもないです まあ それはまだわからないかもしれませんだけど
まあ一応一旦仮説として置いておきましょう
人間には解決できない問題
瞬間瞬間いろんな問題に立ち向かいますが
解決できない問題一つもないという仮説
いくなれば すべての人類は幸福であるはずなんです
だから そちらに出てくる問題なんでしょうかね
もしそれ その仮説は正しければ
解決できない問題一つもないと
正しければどうでしょう
なぜそれだったら我々に解決できない問題あるんですか？それは問題一つ言えるのは
問題の取り方が違う 例えば十名十メートルも入りません
六メートルぐらい あるいは八メートルぐらい長い何か棒があるんだとか
それはこの部屋に持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
こちらに必要なんです
横に何か建てて置こうとしてたら
それでその人がこうやって持ってくるんです
部屋に入らないんです
なんで入らないんですか？って
あの棒を取っているやり方は違うでしょ
そんな縦に持っていったっても
ドアがもうそんな八メートルぐらいないんだから入りません
そこでその人は二つしなくちゃいけないんです
一つはドア壊す あるいは持ってきた棒をドアから入るぐらいに壊す
どちらにしても壊すことでしょ
そこで結果がドア壊しちゃったら何の意味もないんですね
ドアも壁も全部壊しちゃったら
あの棒は部屋に持ってきたっても
その役割を果たせなくなっちゃうんです
じゃあ棒をドアから入れるように壊しちゃったらどうしますか？破ったら
そうするとこちらは長い八メートルの棒必要でしたけど
これないんでしょうに
二メートル半二メートル半のもう何本かしか
で 役に立たないんでしょ
我々ずっとやっているのはそんなことなんです
生きているは人類は 問題の取り方に悪いアプローチが違うんです
あの棒を間違って取っているんです
だから棒を壊すことは自分の破壊という風に理解してください
ドアを壊すことは世界の破壊だと思ってください
そうすると人類はそのどっちでもやってるんじゃないんですか
ある人々は自分が負けると
もう犯罪を起こしたりで社会に迷惑かける
ある人々は自分に迷惑かける
だから私が言うのは 十メートルの棒でもこの部屋の中には確実に入ります
問題はありません 方法はあるんです
その方法でやってください
時々この十階も二十階
四十階の建物の上にでっかいクレーンとか止まってるでしょ
あれどうやって運ぶんですかね
ちゃんと車もつけてるし
動かすこともできますけどね
あれ 階段上ってる？何のことないでしょう
運び方があるんです だから二十階の建物の上見たっても
上ものすごいデッカいクレーンがあって
そこで建物をもう作っているんだから
もし私たちに言ったならばね
このまあクレーン持って渡してそのまま運ぶと思うかもしれません
そうするとそれはできませんね
そういうことをしたと
それは問題でしょうに
解決しなくちゃいけない
それでそちらはもう分かりやすいことだから
そちらの世界で何のこともなく
全部適当に分解して上に持っていって
上で組み立てる それですごいこれクレーンが上にあるんです
建物を作って終わったところで
何のこともなく 壁 1つも傷をつけないで
もしかするとエレベーターで降ろすかもしれませんよ
だから我々には解決できない問題一つもないはず
もし解決できないと思ったら
これは取っているところは違うんだと
そこから取るんじゃないんだと
と覚えておけば それぐらいで智慧が現れる可能性あります
アプローチ変えようと
例えば真理を知るために
智慧が現れるために お釈迦様は言うのは真理を勉強しなさい
嘘を勉強するんじゃなくて真理を目指せと
それでお釈迦様自分がおっしゃったことでも真理と言うんですね
ダンマと言うんですね
でもお釈迦様はこう言うんです
自分のことを勉強する場合は
蛇を捕まるような感じでやってください
すごい すごい言葉と私は思いますけどね
私たちは蛇を捕まえたければ毒蛇
もう毒持って どうやって捕まればいいんですかね
ちゃんときっちりと手で素で掴む場合はね
機械ではなくて きちんと蛇の頭で掴まなくちゃいけないでしょう
そうすると体中蛇の体
我々の体中 蛇の体があっちいぐるぐるぐるぐるいくら回ったっても何のこともないんです
体汚くなるわけでもない
猫はもっと汚いんだからね
体中怪我とかあだこと入りますからね
ホコリだらけで鼻に入っちゃうし
蛇はそんなこと何もないんです
ですから そういう風に体あっちこち巻いちゃっても何のこともないんです
でも 蛇は一番取りやすいところはどこですか
蛇は藪の中で逃げてるでしょ
一番取りやすいところはどこ
首？しっぽでしょうに
蛇がここを人間見たら逃げるんだから
こっちは後ろから行くんだから
しっぽで一番取りやすいんです
そこで蛇の尾っぽの方取ったらどうなるんですかね
自分を噛まれてその場で死んじゃう
自分が あるいは死ぬか
大変な苦しみを味わう
だから この生きるために必要な蛇を見たら
あ この辺で逃げていくんだ
だから知恵っていうのは
じゃあこちらから行って
こうやって取ったらいいんだと
簡単に取れるところで取るんじゃないんです
だから人間 なぜ人生が間違えますかというと
この簡単なやり方でやろうとする
もうちょっと考えた方がいいんです
例えば科学発展は決して悪いことではないんだけど
結局地球自体もひどい状態になっても生きていられない
地球自体は そういう風になったでしょうね
それなぜですかね 簡単な方でやっているんだ
全部簡単な方 例えばもう米とか
米じゃないですね 水田とかなんとか作ったりすると
まあ虫が来て食べるんだと
葉っぱと じゃあ撒きましょう
殺虫剤 すごい簡単で早いんですね
結果は 一回一回二回ぐらいは
それですごい問題が起こる
大量に美味しいんだと
じゃあ化学肥料を使いましょうと
すごい合理的だと思ってるんですね
どうなるんですか？そこで今フロンガス使いません
使ってるかどうかわかりませんだけどね
これは便利やと この便利だと思った途端
すごい落とし穴がそこにあるんですね
そこで地球の大気そのものが大変な危険な状態に
まあ年年待たないと戻らないぐらい大変なことになってしまって
でもそれはその計算もあまり正しくない
未だに全てのフロンガスが大気に行ってないんです
大変なことなんです 我々毎日使っているこのビニールの関係のものっていうのはたくさん使っているでしょうね
あれを発見した時はすごいものを発見したんだと
こんなデュラブルで簡単で軽くて
また強くて また安くて
すごいと じゃないでしょうに
今見ると あれ何ガスですか？あれから燃やすと出てくるのは
あのビニールなんか燃やしちゃうと
あのダイオキシン あれは無知な人のやり方
ベトナムで戦争終わった時はもうアメリカ軍隊が平気でこれ森は全部燃やしてしまえば敵が見つかるんだ
すごい簡単な方法 人間狩りに
そこでいっぱいダイオキシンまいてしまって
いかに残酷 いまだにもうものすごい問題なんです
子供には手はないわ 足はないわで
もうディフォルメしたことを毎日毎日
でも見ようともしない
そんなことはないんだと
平気で言うんだよ 何のことない
だからわかりますかね
この知恵がないんだから
すべての問題があるんです
それはもう国際的な問題であろうが
環境的な問題であろうが
国の問題であろうが 社会の問題であろうが
家庭内の問題であろうが
学校の問題であろうが
そこで一切の問題をまとめているんです
知恵がないんだからなんです
だからどんな問題にも解決する方法あります
あるんだけど 人の手がすぐしっぽで捕まろうとする
そこで蛇が回ってきて噛む
それで大変な苦しみを得ると
だからもうちょっと待ってということはないんです
ちょっと待って それからこの知恵っていうのはすごい面白いもんなんです
皆様ももしかすると将棋やら碁やらいろんなゲームね
カードのゲームやるでしょうと思いますけどね
なんであんなことやって何を楽しむんですかね
見てると全然もう まあ例えばもう相撲でもやってると見ていられますけど
将棋なんかやってると見るの何もないでしょうに
2 3分経ったら まあ一つ小さな石をちょっと前に
じっと待ってて待ってて
また他の それだけなんですけど
でもあれは人間にとってはすごいいい面白いゲームでしょうね
テレビでも放映するんだから
もう何時間もかけて あれは人間の知恵のゲームでしょ
知恵というか知識というかね
だからかなり面白いんです
だからおせんべい食べてて面白い
楽しい 人生は幸せだというよりは
あの何かジグソーパズルでも
あるいはクロスワードパズルですか
いろいろあるでしょうね
あれを 1つ解読することは面白いです
もっと快感というものは得られるのです
だから人間には一番このいろんな楽しみがあるんですが
その中でものすごくいい楽しみっていうのは
やっぱり知恵と知識の世界なんですね
だから私たちはいろんな本を読んだり
読んだり いろんなことをしたり
頭を刺激させてるんです
その方が楽しいんです
だから問題ない人生っていうのは究極的な不幸な人生なんです
次から次へと問題ある人はもうそれぐらい幸福なんです
でもそこで知恵を使ってきちんと解決しなくちゃ幸福はないんです
しっぽで蛇の尾っぽの方に捕まってみたら
まあやられちゃいますと
ですから私の仮説に戻りますけど
人類に解決できない問題一つもない
じゃあだったら なんで人間にはそれほど解決できない問題がたくさんあるんですか？言うと
その問題の取り方 アプローチが違う
10メートルの棒を縦に持ってきたっても
部屋に入るわけじゃないんです
蛇は尾っぽを捕まるもんじゃないんです
だから たとえお釈迦様の教えにしたっても
それぐらい気をつけなさいということを言っているんです
だからお釈迦様は堂々と真理を語っていることなんです
私が言うことは真理だから
皆様信仰しなさい 信じてくださいと
そんなことは言わないんです
気をつけろ だから気をつけて取りなさいということで
やっぱりしっかり智慧のことを教えているんだということがお分かりになるでしょう
もしある経典の中で私こそ経典の王様やと言ったならば
それ自体でその経典がインチキ嘘やってことはわかるでしょうに
簡単単純なのに なんで威張るんですかね
中身がないからでしょう
もし経典には人類には必要なすごいことが書いてあるんだったら
読めばわかるでしょうに
それぐらいは 何もない場合は脅し文句いっぱい書いた
この経典批判したらもう重罪
仏教では愚逆罪というすごい罪
一つついてるんですけど
愚逆罪を犯したよりも罪深いんだとかね
だからただそれだけの言葉で
私個人的にはあの経典を捨てる
僅かでも脅しやったら
じゃ勝手にしろ じゃあ脅してみろという感じで
ですから お釈迦様の教えにはもう僅かな脅しもないんです
例えば悪いことをしたら悪い結果になりますよということは脅しじゃないでしょうに
そんなことは そうなるんだからそう言ってるだけで
だからやってみるか やめるかは
それは個人の自由である
仏教では自分の母親父親は殺すなと大事にしなさいと
不幸になるんだと 自分の命を大事に守ってくれと
自分のために自分の命でも捨てたいぐらい愛情を持って育てた人に迷惑かけてみたら
それはどれぐらい本人がね
非人間的で悲しみ苦しみかっていうことももう切りがないんだから
それは当たり前のことなんです
そういうのは じゃあまあ一応そこら辺で
で まあポイント入れ替えましょう
だから次に皆様が聞きたがるのは
この我々はこういろんな問題に出会うならば
その問題を必ずしも解決できるならば
アプローチが違うというならば
じゃあどのようにどんなアプローチでよろしいかということなんです
問題が起きたらどんなアプローチでよろしいかと
で それには一つの答えがないんです
一つの答えがあったら
それ智慧の世界ではないんです
それがそこで私にも困るところなんですね
それはこの問題そのもの
その問題自体で解決しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 家庭の中で暴力ふる子供がいるんだと
その場合はこうしなさいと言ったところで
地球上すべての子供にそれは合いますかね
そのやり方が 合わないでしょうに
だからその暴力ふる子供の精神的な状態
育てられた両親の状態
勉強する学校の状況 自分の仲間たちのこと
環境とか そこを見たところで答えがそこにあるんであって
あくまでもその答えは
その子供のために特別な解決法であって
だからすべての人類はこのやり方でやってくださいということではないんです
私たちも違う それも一つなんですね
例えばテキストで勉強する
問題の解決法 それ自体間違っているんです
テキストから得られるのは知識のみ
智慧ではありません 問題解決するのは智慧なんです
智慧は自分が作るものなんです
だから心理学の本でも児童心理学の本でも
読むのは構いません 勉強するのは一向に構いませんだけど
だからそのまま応用できるといえば
それはそうではありません
物理学じゃないんだからね
物理学的物理の法則だったら
まああの 何といいますか
この作り方を本を見ながら作ればいいんです
料理も同じですが まあでもそれでもうまくいかないでしょう
例えばモーターの DCモーターの作り方とか
子供たちやることですけど
あってもそれでこいつ回って
もう磁石を入れて電気つなげた
つなげただけで回るわけじゃないんです
あれは それで自分でいろいろ考えて
なんでこれ回らないんですか？とかね
いくらか自分でも調整しなくちゃいけないんです
料理の本があるんだからといって
誰でも究極の美味しい料理できるかというと
そうでもないでしょうに
どこかで自分の能力は
知恵がそこで利くんです
だからもうそれだったら我々知恵のない人に残るのは
もう前もって工場で作っている
冷凍している料理を持ってきて
電子レンジでチンするだけ
それを無知な人々の世界の
何もしなくてもいいと
冷凍したものを持ってきて
電子レンジに入れて そこで蓋を見たら四分ですよと
二百五十ワットで四分ですよ
そこで二百五十ワットにして四分回してもらえば OK と
私たちはそういう生き方が好きなんです
だから仏教とは違う世界を目指しているんです
だから平和な世界ではなくて
戦争の世界を目指しているんです
豊かな世界ではなくて
不幸な世界を目指しているでしょう
犯罪起こる世界を目指しているんです
怠けの世界だから そういうわけで
もうやっぱり百八度 百八十度
やっぱり返りなくちゃいけないんです
生き方自体で まぁこの別に冷凍食品に私は別に恨みあるわけじゃなくて
それはちょっと例で理解しやすくするために出すだけなんですけど
ですから我々毎日立ち向かう問題に
この何かポケットにいつでもメモを書いておいて
この通りにやればいいんだというふうな
この便利な手帳みたいなものはないんです
あるならばそれは知識です
あるいは辞書みたいに
今 今子供はものすごく大きい声で泣いてるんだと
そこで泣くという言葉知り
大きい声で その場合はこうしますと
今自分の奥さんがヒステリー起こしてるから
ヒステリーという言葉
じゃあこの場合はこうしますと
そういう風な知恵の本がないんです
だからそこら辺が面白いです
私たちみんなに平等に
選挙権と同じくみんなにあるんです
知恵を発達する方法 もしお釈迦様でもああいう風に辞書
知恵の辞書を作っておいたならば
人間というのはなんか羊みたいに
虫けらみたいにやられるよりやられっぱなしでしょうに
それはあまり面白い世界はないんですね
そのその人は自分の知恵を発見しなくちゃいけないんです
このやりきれないものがいくらでもあるっていうこと
またすごい面白いんです
毎日知恵の人生だから
毎日何か問題が起こるんだから
うん まぁ大体知恵の生き方っていうのはそういうふうな生き方なんですが
まぁこれからですね まぁ少々それに役に立つ
いくらか あのいわゆる知恵が現れてくるために
ちょっと役に立つヒントをいくつか
考えてみましょう そういうのはヒントのみ
これ何回も言いました
初めて言うポイントはね
何回もあったかも ちょっともう言います
で あの覚えやすいならば
この判断は急ぐな  [背景の騒音]ということは
このいつでも問題が起きたら解決しなくちゃいけないんだから
そこに判断があるんですね
どうするんだと それ急いじゃったらちょっと危ないんです
急ぐなということは本当にただいい言葉じゃないんです
あの 人間はこの判断の仕方が知らないんです
物事を まあこれから判断についていくらか喋りますが
この判断のやり方はわからない
やり方わからないんだから
判断っていうのは ほとんど合わないんですね
問題に 判断でもいいし
答えでもいいし 問題に出会ったら
その問題に我々出す答えっていうのはもう判断だというならば
なぜ判断という言葉を使いますか？と
やっぱりこの これ生き方だから
生きるために判断があって
それは実行しなくちゃいけないんだから
ジャッジメント で どうせこの判断間違っちゃうんですね
この判断を間違うと答えを間違って
その問題の解決 問題は解決しないでしょうに
そこで自分としては問題解決しようとしたんです
逃げようとしたわけじゃないんです
問題解決しようとしたんだけど
どうも結果が良くない
解決できない それだったら自分の判断ミスでしょう
だから判断ミスといえば
それはすごいこと 大変なことなんです
だから 人生においては判断ミス起こらないように気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ と言っても理屈はわかりますね
理屈はわかりますけど
でも判断ミスさせてはいけないから
これは誰にでも言えることなんですけど
じゃあそれだったらなぜ判断ミス起こすんですかね
その我々は判断ミスを起こすあの四つの事柄があります
この四つの事柄がよく覚えておいてください
この四つの事柄 その説明これからゆっくりとしますけど
この我々の心の中で四つのいわゆる固定概念みたいなもの
偏見みたいなもの 変な感情が四つあるんです
そこで見て そこがあって
その色眼鏡で見て判断するんです
そうするとはっきりと間違う
一番目はチャンレと言うんですね
チャンレは日本語ではどのように言えばいいでしょうかね
これ 意欲みたいなもの訳でもよろしいし
好みでもいいんですね
で 意欲っていう場合は
この まあこの一番目のことは
仏教ではいいことを通しても悪いことを通しても同じ言葉を使っているわけです
で 意欲といえば 仏教ではいい方向に入れてるんです
この四つの場合は これ悪いという意味なんです
ですから 意欲という言葉は良くないんです
ですから 好みみたいな
言葉でいいかもしれません
例えば まあ説明すると
私たちは何か問題にぶつかっちゃう
ぶつかったところで この問題を解決する前に
以前 自分には自分の好みがあるんです
その自分の好みがあるんだから
そこはもうその方向へ
問題が動くように判断してしまいちゃう
自分が得する方向へ だから自分が得する方向へ問題を持っていくことは
問題の答えではないんです
その問題から新しい問題が起こるだけ
問題はありとあらゆる方向で枝分かれになって増えるだけ
そこ自分の好みがあると頭が綺麗じゃないんですね
知識人じゃないんですね
まあこれあのゲンマの極端的な例で説明するとわかりやすい
例えばもう何か法律的な問題があって
あの警察が誰かを訴えてしまったと裁判で
そこで裁判やってる裁判官がこの被告人って何？何人ですか？被告人 Accused
その人を見たら結構可愛いんだと
まあ例えば女性にしましょう
まあなかなかの美人だと
自分の好みだと それでもう警察側がこの人はこうこうやって人を騙してこれぐらいお金取ったんだと
ああいうところでこういうこういう態様
こういうこういうことしたんだと
いろいろ証拠を出す そこでこのとんでもない裁判官がもう判決出す場合は無罪だと
まあそんなことは世の中であり得ないんだけど
まあ別にこの例で考えてください
例えばその女の人が自分の美しさを誘って人を殺したこともあると
そこまでは世の中であります
別に 裁判官から見ればなかなかの美人で
そこで 無罪にしてあげる
それでいいと思いますか？とんでもないでしょうに
そこで彼が無罪にしたところで
私もあんた可愛いんだからね
一応無罪にしましたよと
それで問題終わりますかね
終わらないんでしょ その人は小さな問題を数えられないほど膨大な問題を作ったことになります
その人自体も 自分の人生はそれで終わってしまう
社会問題作るわ 自分の仕事もクビも飛んじゃうわ
と言ったら そんなことは私も世の中でそんなことはほとんどないということを言ったんだけど
我々は日常生活の中で嫌になるほど同じことをやってるんです
問題が起きたら好みで判断する
自分の好みで 主観で この好みというもの生まれたら客観的に物事を見えなくなるんです
これ人類持ってる大変な問題なんです
例えば国際的な問題 いろいろできる
出来上がっちゃう場合は
この国ごとに判断おかしいでしょ
全部好みで 自分の好きな味方の国がやってることは全部よろしい
味方でない国がやってることは全部間違ってるって平気で
この世の中で毎日あるでしょう
それで何がなる？何になるかというと
問題はどんどんどんどん複雑に複雑になって
解決方法ないくらいおかしくなっちゃうんです
例えばイスラエル人とパレスチナ人の問題でも
ここまで膨張してむちゃくちゃになったのは
一つはあれなんです 好み
ですから たとえ小さなことにしたっても
だから個人的に気をつければ
小さなことで判断する場合は
自分の好き嫌いではやらないんだと
私は好きだから ということで
すぐそうなるんです だから
よっぽどの智慧の人でないと
心は冷静で 物事を全部客観的に見て
こうだからこうなって
こうなって こうなって
答えはこうですとは言えませんと
またちょっとわかりやすい他の例に置き換えると
例えば自分の子供は隣の子供
例えば学校の先生がいて
その先生の子供は他の子供と喧嘩したとした
それはその先生は調べなくちゃいけない
その時点で このもう一人の子供はちょっと不安
でしょ 例えば二人が喧嘩したんだけど
それ調べる先生見ると一人が先生の息子なんです
そうすると向こうの子供はそれだけでも嫌なんです
でも もしそうなったならば
これ私の子供だから 私の子は庇ってあげなくちゃいけないんだとか
という感じでやると もう百パーセント間違い
そういう間違いで庇ってあげたかもしれませんだけど
自分が自分の子供にもすごいダメージ与えたことになるんです
それだけじゃない 他の人
子供たちにすごい信頼を失っちゃうんです
私は一つだけそういうことを覚えているんです
で 私が小学校にいた時は
教えたある先生が自分の子供三人ぐらいいたかな
みんな同じ学校で勉強しているんですね
で 私のクラスにはいなかったんだけど
一人は私より二年か二年か一年下でしたけど
でも先生の息子たちだから
いつでも先生のところでよろよろやったりはしましたし
ですからみんなのこと知っている
私はもうガキの悪いのによく見ていたのは
その先生 自分の子供は特別扱いするかしないか
やっぱり子供にとってはすごく気になるんです
自分の子供だからみんないたずらするんです
だからもう先生に叱られる場合はもう切りがなく叱られる状況でしたけど
やっぱりそれでも もしその人を特別扱いされたらということはすごく気になるんです
だから自分にとっては直接関係なかったんだけど
クラスが違うんだから
年違うんだから やっぱり自分も覚えてるんです
すごく それどうかな この人は自分の子供に特別扱いするかなとか見ていたんです
もし特別扱いしていたならば
私は子供の時どんな努力するかというと
あの先生のことは全く信頼しない
いわゆる頼りにならない人やとということになっちゃうんですね
その先生はそんなことなかったんだけど
まあ結構もう厳しいんですね
もう ですから問題なかったんだけど
でもあの女の先生の場合はよくあったんです
今言ったのは男の先生なんです
女の先生たちも 自分の子供を同じ学校にいる場合
いつでも時間作って そこ自分の子供のところに行っていちいちいちいちいろんなこと面倒見てあげたり
そうすると私 それは不公平だと
これ学校だから これはダメやと
それだったら だから母親だから自分の子供の面倒を見るのは当たり前ではないか
それは私にガキの頃もその論理はなかったんです
それだったら我々も自分たちの母親を学校に連れて行くんですかね
本を片付けてくれるとかね
机拭いてくれるとか それが自分の子供だから
女の先生がやってもすっごく嫌で
これはいけないんだ 学校で私たちは私たちのことを自分でやるんだったら
あなたも自分のことを自分でやらなくちゃいけないんだと
で 自分がこの女の人は何言ったっても聞かんと
バカにしてやるぞと もう決めていたんです
だから これ自分のすごい昔の
四十年前の話ですけど
だから人間みんな平等だから
私は今の世界でも同じことだと思います
ですから この判断する場合は
この好みでいくというすごい怖いこと
これすっごい怖いんです
ものすごい良くないんです
なのに世の中で毎日あるんです
政治的な判断 経済的な判断
それ何やろうとも自分の好みでやってしまう
例えば会社で三人 あの汚職
なんとかして三人なんか調べるようになったところで
その中でもやっぱり一番もう他の人が嫌になっている人とかね
そういう人は捕まるようにして
この人はもう仲がいいんだからと
我々のことなんとかしてくれるとか言って
と 考えちゃうんですね
そういう 例えばまあ いつでも私たちはそういうことをやる恐れがいつでもあるんです
例えば 自分が知っていた人が何か間違っている犯罪ことをしましたと
そこで自分 自分に何か手助けすることできるならば
自分知っている人だから
なんとかそこから逃げるようになんとかしてあげようということになっちゃうんです
お釈迦様はそういう点ではすごい厳しいんで
たとえ自分の子供であろうか
問題を起こしたら ただ独立した人間が問題を起こしました
そこは客観的にどういう結果かと判断しなくちゃいけないんです
法律はそうなってますよ
例えばアメリカの大統領の息子
娘であろうかの問題が起きて起こったら
まあきちんと法律で大統領の特別力は使うことは不可能ですけど
これアメリカとかはまあそこはできるかもしれませんけど
それでも裏でいろんなことやりますからね
時々ありますよ 国々では大統領の息子は平気でも法律を起こしたり
汚職をしたり 金を取ったり
ワイロを取ったりすると
平気でやるんです いろんなこの管理官も関係の偉い人々やらにも
大統領の息子はただの息子なんですけど
何のことに電話かけてあんた何々さんで
これ何々さんが喋ってますが
これなんとか何とかやってくださいと平気で頼んだりする
まあ具体的な例で言うならば
まあその場合は自分の国のことしか
他のこと言ったら失礼だからね
言いたいことはいくらでもありますけど
この自分の国の前の政府の場合は
男の人が大統領をやっていましたからね
その人まあ亡くなったんだけど
その人の奥さんがまあただまあどこかの小さな喫茶店とか何とかやっていた女の人なんです
そこでそのもう顔を会わせて気に入って結婚したんです
だからまあ別に国のこと見るぐらい知識も能力も何もある人ではなかったし
今もないし で 男の人はすごい頑張り屋で頭が良かったんだけどね
まあかなり頑張って もう弱肉強食の世界でもう敵は全部壊して
とにかく大統領になりました
この女の人が大統領ファーストレディーでしょ
あっちこっちも電話かけて
あの あの あの なんとか人にこの仕事をあげなさいと
あんたこうしなさいとかね
全く平気で 完全たる法律違反でしょうに
だから大統領は政治家だから政治的な判断するのは
それはそちらの法律的なやり方であって
この女の人があっちこっち
そこで変なことをしたところで
大統領は時々怒っちゃうところあるでしょうに
そこで大統領は自分の旦那だから
その人を怒るんですね
大変な危機状態でものすごい買ったんだから
だからそういうことっていうのは
もうものすごい人類不幸になることなんです
だから たとえ大統領の息子であろうか何か犯罪を起こしたら
大統領の権限なんか使うんじゃなくて
一つの独立した人間として扱わなくちゃいけない
ですから その厳しさ 我々は自分にも
自分の子供たちにも 周りの友達たちにも
誰にでも持たなくちゃいけないんです
あんた友達は それは友達は分かりますけど
これやったことは悪いんですと
例えば私の友達がいる
それで私にとってまたすごく嫌な人もいる
そこで私にとって嫌なことする人を友達がいて殴ったんですよ
そこで一つの法律を犯したことになりましたから
そこでその友達が警察
そこら辺にいる場合は助けてくださいと
あんた友達でしょうと
言っても あんた友達であることは確かなんですけど
やったことは良くない
で 自分の国の警察の人々
まあよくみんなと仲良くしたくなりますけど
我々のは一般的なことわざあるんですね
いくらニコニコと仲良くしても
警察だけは絶対信じるな
なぜか なぜかというと
例えば自分が何か何かしたところで
向こうで捕まるでしょうに
その時は知らんふりするんですね
まあ例えばちょっと事故を起こしたとかなんとかあったら
それ捕まって何か部屋に入れて鍵かけてそのまま放り出しちゃうでしょうに
お茶一杯ぐらいでも知らんふり
知らんふりもするし もっとその人々はすごく忙しくなっちゃうんですね
警察の人は 来てあちこち走って
やっぱり自分を知ってる人だから
まあでもだからといって何かしたくはないんですね
だから本当にその点では立派なんですね
友達は友達なんですけど
問題を起こしたら それはまあどうしようもない
だからそういう風に何かすごいこの残酷みたいに感じるかもしれませんだけど
このその生き方は正しいです
そうすると正しい判断できるんです
正しい判断したら 次から次へと問題は起こりません
ですから この身っていうのは我々の判断を間違う
智慧が無くなる 大変な問題なんです
番目はどうせわかりやすい怒りですね
この身の反対 こういうことを
例えば子供たちのクラスがあると思いましょう
そこで一人の子供がよくいたずらするんだと
先生をからかったりもするんだと
そこでもう頭の痛い総裁だと
いっそで そこで何か学校で何か先生の財布がなくなったでしょ
あるいはあっちクラスの中でタバコの吸い殻が見つかったりする
そうすると その先生はいつでも自分を悩ませてるんだから
その子は何かいたずらしているんだから
言うこと聞かないんだから
いきなりその子を捕まっちゃうでしょ
あなたではないか はっきり言いなさい
嘘言ったわけません なんだこんなこといじめたりする
そこでこの番目でもう判断間違っているんです
嫌だからね もともとその人のこと
だから心が あ おそらくこれもあいつがやったんではないかということになっちゃうんですね
そこでタバコ吸ってあっちこちばらまいてるのも
もしかするといっそでもすごい顔をして
真面目な顔をしている子かもしれませんね
でも見ようとも思い出せないんで
その場合は その子だったらそんなことをやるはずがないと
こんなことやるんだったらもうもう確かにあいつやと思っちゃうでしょ
でもそれは無知的な判断である
だからそういう風に私たちは主観で間違っちゃうと
ところでもどうすか 番目はばやくっていうのは怖いんだから
ということで 自分に危険が来るんだからとかね
で なぜ政治家がしっかりと政治やらないかというと
選挙で負けたらということ
だから正しい判断 例えばある国を豊かに幸せにしたいければ
次の選挙で負けても勝ってもどうでもいいんだと
私はこの年 年 年間 これやらなくちゃいけないんだから
しっかりやるんだと なんたらの機嫌を取るんじゃなくて
国の責任を取らなくちゃいかないんだということでやるはずなんですけど
一人もそんなことをやりません
どんな国の政治家でも
自分を応援しているバカどもの機嫌取ろう取ろうと
釣りばっかし だからその恐怖ということも人間ダメにするんですね
番目はわかりやすくて
無知 智慧がない 頭が悪いと
まあそれはわかりやすく判断できませんね
それでも人間っていうのはすぐ判断してしまう
問題が起きたらもう判断してしまっちゃう
だからその判断自体間違ってるんだから
一個の問題がもういろんな枝分かれでいろんな問題に膨張してしまっちゃうんです
だから問題に答えがあるんです
どんな問題にも解決法はあるんです
なぜ間違うかというと
この四つで汚れていない人々はいないんです
この世の中に だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
このすごい知識的な 徹底的な
インテリ的な生き方っていうのは
そういう生き方で 生きる場合はもう感情はなし生き方
こういうこの四つの感情
まあ感情では上の三つなんですけど
四番目は智慧がないってことだからね
まあ感情とは言えませんだけど
だからなんとなくなんか味がないかなと感じるかもしれませんだけど
なんかちょっと感情がない
なんかすごいドライな生き方ではないかと
でもドライじゃないんですよ
智慧の世界っていうのはものすごい刺激的で面白いんです
ドライだったらなんで皆様方
将棋やらね いろんなことやってるんですかね
そんなことじゃないんです
例えば自分の子供にしたっても
客観的に一人の人間として見て
あんたが間違ってるんだと厳しく見たところで
親のことを嫌いになるんじゃなくて尊敬しちゃうんです
正しい判断しちゃったら
だから自分がもう 40年前のことを覚えてるんだから
もう世の中何も知らない年でしたけど
やっぱりそれでも人間っていうのは本能としてそれを持ってるんです
だから先生たちはね こんなちくちく遊んでるガキどもがね
そんなこと知らんだろうと勘違いしてるんだけど
向こうは厳しくチェックしていたんだから
だから自分がやったんだから
私は今も我々も大人 じじいになっちゃったんだけど
子供にきちんともう監視されているんだっていうことはもう知ってる
私は知ってますけど だから皆様方もいつでも子供だから
厳密に我々のきめ細かい行動まで監視しているんです
そこでそういう感情だったら必ずもう馬鹿にされる
尊敬されません 信頼されません
だから結局我々はいつでも厳しい世界で生きてるんです
だから私のこの話を聞いたら
やっぱり仏教というのはすごいドライな世界よ
違うんです もともとはそんなものに生きてるんです
我々は感情で あの人のこと可愛いんだから
あなただったらいいよ
許せますと でもあなただったらダメやということで生きてますけども
結局馬鹿にされてるんです
ですから この判断の場合は
この 4つですごく気を付ける
すごい知識的な まぁ将棋だと思った方がいいんです
将棋やってる場合は感情が出たらできないでしょうに
何が起こるか すごくクールでコマンドの配列を見てみるしか方法ないんです
人の顔を見たらできなくなっちゃうんです
まあその場合もずるいやり方ありますよ
人の顔を見て馬鹿にするとかね
あんた相手にはならんとかね
本当はすごい相手の方怖いんですね
相手にならんって言ったら向こうが怒るんです
怒った途端頭が働くなくなっちゃうんです
そういうふうに怒るか
あるいは褒め殺しにするかとかなんとかと
最初からもうまあ本当にこれは勝負にならない
あなたとはね こんなもうもうなんか面白くないでしょ
あなたに勝ったらね そんなに強くて私にも教えてくださいとか
ああいうとこ行っちゃうと
向こうは自分の安全装置を失っちゃうでしょうね
そこで勝てるんですからね
そういうのはずるいやり方ですよ
それで面白いわけじゃないんで
ですからあくまでも将棋の人生ですから
クールで冷静で あの人は三冠王か十冠王か
それはどうでもいいんです
相手が 自分でクールで冷静で動かせばいいんですね
人生もその同じやり方
ですから 判断の世界ではこの 4つを避けましょう
それは普通の生き方で
それからもっと哲学的な
もうちょっとレベル高く考えちゃうと
判断というのは不可能なんです
すべての判断はある側面だけ見ているものですから
偏見に過ぎないんです
それもこの高いレベルで覚えておかなくちゃいけない
例えばある人を見て あ
その人は可愛いんだと
それはその人の持っているある
一つの側面を見ただけなんです
一人の人っていうのは数えられないほど持ってるんですよ
いろんな側面 ですから
判断しちゃったらそこは偏見なんです
だからこの 難しい 判断がないんです
いつでも出せる絵っていうのは
バラの花きれいですから
世の中で決めつけてるんです
綺麗ですと それまた間違ってる
決めつけてる判断だから
バラの花は綺麗ですということは
この世の中にあるすべてのバラの花が綺麗ですということだから
言うこと自体間違っているし
その言った人がこの地球上であらわ咲いてくる一切のバラの花を研究したわけじゃないでしょうに
感情で ただたまたま何かなんか何本かバラの花を見て
その時の感情で綺麗と映しただけで
それで決めちゃう バラの花は綺麗ですと
そこで人類の知恵としてそれで伝わっているんだから
とんでもない世界なんですね
我々生きている世界っていうのは
誰かの まあ偏見は普遍的な真理になるでしょう
だから我々は使っている言葉を調べてみてください
ほとんどそういうことでしょうね
だから言葉として 知識として知恵が出てこない
言葉自体 知識自体偏見だからね
あれインドの論理学でよく出てくる例なんでしょ
あの  山の 山には煙があるゆえに
山には火がある 山 山火事ですよと
パーロト それはサンスクリット語で
それ昔の何でしたっけ
この あの論理書で書で書いてます
パーロトワフニマンドゥーマトゥアヤタマハナサ
ただそれだけの行なんです
パーロトワフニマンドゥーマトゥアヤタマハナサということは
山には火事がある 山火事がある
なぜならば煙が出ている
なぜならば 例えば台所だと
ってぐらいの だから昔の台所でこの薪であの料理する
だから薪を入れたら 火を焚いたら必ずも煙が出る
だから火があるところに必然的に煙があるということが出てくるんです
そこで逆に計算して山に煙がある
ですから必然的に火がありますということになるんですね
まあよっぽど間違っている論理じゃないかもしれませんだけど
仏教というのはそれを間違っているんだと
それはあくまでも推測にしか
何もないんだ だから 故に私はおそらく山にも
山の上にもおそらく火があるかもしれませんという風に気をつけて言わなくてはいけない
でも私たちはそんな気をつける世界ではないんです
まあ平気で言っちゃう
この普通のマスコミの世界で書いてる文章なんか見たら
まあ知識にはひとかけらも助けてくれない
もう全部判断してくれて
すぐに明かされる なんとか
なんとかどうか もうなんとか
なんとか人の なんとか
なんとか問題は まあすぐに解明しますとかね
ただすっごい言葉で書く
そういう言葉に我々ももう惹かれるとか
そういうすごい怖い世界
無知の世界 ですから この
たとえバラの花綺麗ですというのは
そんなのはいい加減な言葉だと思った方がいいんです
判断の言葉だから 世界にあるすべてのバラの花は綺麗わけじゃないし
ものすごく小さなバラの花もいて
虫に食われて まあ無茶苦茶な花もあるし
綺麗じゃないものもいっぱいあるし
そこで綺麗と言ったっても
それはあくまでもその人の感情であって
小さい時から子供にこれは食べ物だと
野菜だと教え込んじゃったら
その子供にとってはそれただの野菜になってしまっちゃいます
だからコールフラワーは美しいと誰も思ってないでしょ
思ってません？コールフラワーっていうのはすごい美しい
日本語でもコールフラワーというんですよね
あの え？何？え？そういう
あれ美しいと思わないでしょうに
立ててあげようとかね
玄関に あれはもう花でしょうに
でも小さい時からあれは食べるものだと
野菜だと教え込まれてるんだから
全然花では 花として感じないんです
だから花は綺麗ですという言葉自体いい加減でしょ
[鼻をすする音]そこで人間というのはグロテスクなものはすごく普通は感情的には嫌がるんですね
ゴキブリでも嫌がるし
ムカデ見たっても嫌だと思っちゃうし
ちょっとグロテスクだから
でも教え込まれたらグロテスクの虫とか捕まって遊んだりもする
ザリガニ ザリガニもグロテスクなんですけど
でも 見たら逃げたくなるほどすっごいかっこ悪い魚がいるんですね
なんとかなんとか名前の
私は今思い出すのはアンコウなんとかという魚がいる
すごいもうグロテスク
でも教え込まれてるんですね
これすっごい高級な食べ物です
そんなもんなんです  それで私が言いたかったのは
この判断というのはしにくいもんだということで
物事にはこのいくらでも側面があります
例えば私が何者ですかと私にさえ一言葉で説明できますかね
私はこういうものですよと一言葉で言えますかね
自分でも知らないほどいろんな側面がありますから
私は人間に喋る場合は同じ態度を取るかというと全く違うんです
皆様と喋る喋る態度と
電車あちこちで誰か来て喋ると
その時の態度と 別に個人個人的に喋る時の態度と
外国人と喋る時までそれぞれすごくすごく違うんです
戦闘で会う人々と喋る時の態度も
まるっきり自分で考えたって
これは一人の人間かといえば
もう一千万人ぐらいの人か
とスマナサーラというやつは
それぐらい違うんです
だからそこで本当の自分というのはどちらですかね
これって決められませんでしょ
例えば今説法している時間は本物のスマナサーラ
それ私二十四時間の中でほんの二時間半ぐらいの時間だから
だからそれだけで決められますかね
だからもうまず判断不可能ということを覚えておいた方が一番智慧の世界
すごく智慧 だからたまに判断しても
その場でその条件の中でこういう判断ですよと決めた方がいいんです
だから考え方というのはものすごく早く
恐ろしい速さでゴロゴロ変わるんだったら
それは智慧の世界なんです
逆に言えば 例えば人を見て
あんた本当にもう嫌な人やと思って
次の瞬間 あんた結構可愛いですよと
いう人正しいんです だから嫌な側面見たら
あんた本当に嫌な人やと
また見たら嫌な側面だけじゃなくて可愛い側面持ってます？あんた結構可愛いですよとかね
だからはっきり言うならば
もう一分見ないでも百ぐらい考え方が変わるならば
その人はその場その場で見えることでしょう
だから決めつけてはいけないんですね
そういう風な あの 頑張ると智慧が生まれてきます
まだたくさんありますが
それからこの問題が起きたりすると
次のポイント あれじゃないか
行動しなくちゃいけないということがありました
特に我々はいろいろ目的作るんですね
目的ということも一つの判断なんですね
だから私はこの目的のために生きてるんだということが生きやすいかもしれませんだけど
その目的そこでそれを目指して頑張るということは
自分が自分の目を閉じて他のものを見えないようにして
変な生き方をするんだということも決まってるんです
それ自体も智慧の生き方じゃないんです
生き方不自然になりますから
でも だからといって目的作ることは我々には避けられない世界でもありますから
だからこの簡単に何か目的を作ったら
じゃあこれでやるぞ それはよくない
ものすごく自分が生きるためにこれから何かしますよと思ったならば
その目的をすっごくすっごく観察して観察して決めなくちゃいけない
いきなり飛び出して行動にする人々はものすごいダメージ
他人にも自分にも するんです
ですから 目的が出たならば
その目的は本当に達するべきものか
自分に対してそれは本当にいいものになるだろうかと
それから自分にはいいかもしれませんだけど
それによって他の生命のど
状態はどうですかと 他人に迷惑をかけるかかけないかと
そういう風にいろんなことを考えなくちゃいけない
それから その達する目的の場合も
この long term という short term 二つあるでしょう
例えば医者になりますということは long term 目的なんですね
若い人が医者になりますと決める
それその人の人生全部決めることだから
これは long term なんですね
それでまあ鎌倉に行って遊び
大仏さんでも見ますということが short term でしょう
だから目的にはそれ そう二つありますね
すぐ目的を達成したらそれで終わりと
目的を達成したらそれで終わるんじゃなくて
それで長い間 それは自分には影響あるんだという二種類あることを考えてほしいんですね
だから この世の中でよく言うのはちゃんと目的作って頑張れとかね
そういう無責任な言葉ではなくて
その作る目的自体はどのものかと
自分には本当にプラスか
自分にプラスかもしれませんけれど
他人に社会にどっかで迷惑かけるかかけないかと
それだけでは足りません
これはどういう目的が
これ short term ですか
long term ですかと
これ日本語にするとどうなりますかね
この short term
long term というのは
長期間 短期間  これまあ長期間影響を与える目的か
あるいは短期間のものかと
で そこを考えたところで
その その問題なんですよ
目的があるということは問題なんです
じゃあそこら辺極めたところで
次に道ということができるわけですね
だから いとも簡単に解決もできますよ
例えば short 短期間のことだったら
これ命かけてやる必要はないんでしょうし
だから目的達するということは
自分がかなり能力 財産
使うということなんです
いわゆるダメージを受けるということなんです
何か自分が犠牲にしなくちゃいけないんです
何かの目的達するために達するためには
また何か何かたくさんのものを犠牲にしなくちゃいけないんです
だから考えてほしいんですね
だから 自分が犠牲にするものと自分が得るものを比べたら
これ自分に対してなんですけどね
プラスマイナス考えておかなくちゃいけない
それで自分にはいいかもしれません
例えば銀行強盗やったら自分にはいいかもしれませんだけど
まあ社会にとってはどうですかとかね
例えば狩猟やりたいとかね
魚釣りやりたいとかと思ったって
それ魚にとってどうですかとかね
殺される動物にとってどうですかとかね
あっちこっちこの森の中でいろんな探検したいみたいとか言って
まあそれむちゃくちゃ森を破壊したり
自然破壊したりする そこら辺まで考えなくちゃいけない
森は綺麗です 山は綺麗
だからといってそれはもう登るべきかないかと
ですから 目的に達するということは
いろんなものを犠牲にすることだから
そういうところで気をつけて計算する
そこで long term の場合はそれぐらいものを犠牲にしなくちゃいけない
short term の場合はそれなりのことを犠牲にしなくちゃ
その価値があるかと じゃあ価値があると分かったところで
正々堂々とその目的に向かって頑張るんでしょ
そういう疑いがない もやもやがないんです
なぜ人間に目的あるのに人生はもやもやですかね
そこら辺は知恵使ってないんです
誰か他の話したらまた考え方変わっちゃいますから
だからそうやって目的決める
それで次に道 じゃあこの目的に達するためにどうすればいいか
それで自分の頭にある方法浮かぶでしょうね
それでやりますと決めないんです
じゃあこの方法でやればよろしい
でも他の方法もありますよと
もっと簡単に いわゆる犠牲する
犠牲するものを少なくして
その目的に達する方法あるかと
そこら辺も考えてから
もうその人にとっても問題ないんです
もう行動するしか それで行動開始
それから毎日毎日我々が出会う問題を解決するために
あの すぐの手段っていうのは
仏教の智慧の言葉なんですけど
これヤターブータニャーナというんですね
ヤターブータっていうのは如実という風に伝統的には訳されています
如実ですかね ニャーナは智慧
そこで日本語の如実はわかってもわからなくても構いませんだけど
常に私たちにはこの物事の過程について目覚めておかなくちゃいけないんです
あ これでこれでこうなった
これでこれでこうなった
そうすると問題ないでしょ
あ これでこれでこうなったんだから
これダメだったんだ こうこうすればいいやと
すぐそこで答えがあるんです
ですから もし誰かさんにこのヤターブータニャーナがあるならば
その人に解決できない問題は一つもない
それもまだわかりやすい
例えば子供はもう不良になってしまったと
これどういうどういう過程で
どういうどういうわけで不良になったかと分かったならば
まあ解決法はそこにありますでしょ
それくらい私が言わなくたってわかっています
問題はみんな聞くのは
そこわからないんだと
今まではすごくいい子でしたと
今年から すごい変な態度取るようになりましたと
高校一年生まではよくよくできた子でしたと
二年目までは からはもうとんでもないんだと
まるっきりわからないんだという問題なんですね
そこは子どもの場合だけではなくて
いつでも社会でいつでもある問題なんです
なぜかというと 例えば経済状態が悪いんだと
だから悪いんだから 良くなるのは良くするのは当たり前なんですけど
どうすればいいんでしょうかと
全然答えが出てこないんですね
だから如実知見がないんですね
この過程 どのようにしてこの問題が起きたかと
その過程を見るためにはかなり長い時間研究しなくちゃいけないでしょ
ということは智慧が不可能ということになっちゃいますね
でもそれは良くない それではないので答えがあるんです
だから答えがない問題ないんだから
答えがない問題はないんです
どういうことかというと
お釈迦様が言うのは 常に
毎日二十四時間も自分の周りに出来事について目が覚めておきなさい
何が起きているんですか？ちょっと知っておきなさい
ただそれだけ そこでたくさん知る必要ないんです
この時間というのも 例えば十年前で父親に殴られたんだから
私の人生は不幸になってるんだという人がいるんですね
小さい時 母親に捨てられたんだから
あの人が大変扱いしにくい人間になっているんだということを言うでしょう
あれは正しい答えではありません
そんな発見見つかったっても答えがないでしょうに
例えば四十歳の人がいる
まるっきり社会に溶けない
すごい嫌な性格 誰も信頼しない
その代わりに性格が悪いというと調べるんですね
バカどもが 調べたところでは
小さい時 母親に捨てられたんだと
じゃあそれ見つかってその人を直せますかね？だから正しい科学的な直し方っていうのは
その人の時間は全部逆戻してもらう
逆戻してもらって 母親に捨てられないようにしてもらう
それからまた早回しで回してもらうと
ありえないでそんなこと
時間は戻れませんから
ですから ヤターブータニャーナだせるのは如実知見の正しい使い方っていうのは
いつでもこの今の時間だけ
知ること 例えば私は講演先で手を下がる場合は
このマイクロフォンに当たるとする
そこで音するでしょ そこで
あ 手が当たったんだから音が出た
それで終わり 私は落ち着いてないんだから
朝食べたものはなかなか体に合わなくて消化していないんだから苛立っているんだとか
そこまでいったら正しいかないか分からないでしょうに
それで時間を逆戻しにしていいもの食べてきますかね
私は だから我々 この因果法則を探すやり方というのはむちゃくちゃなんです
過去に行くんです 過去は終わったんだから
過去の影響は今ないんです
だから今の瞬間で因果法則を探してみておけと
ですから瞬時に答えが出るんです
瞬時に答えが出るんです
これにはこれと それでこの
例えば自分の子供のことにしたっても
いつでも子供のことについてサティがあったならば
サティという専門用語なんですけど
何やってるかってことを知っているんだと
その瞬間 その瞬間で 今はちょっと怒っているんだと
今は楽しがっているんだと
今なんか私に隠れてちょっと何か小さなことをやっているんだと
だから小さいとか それはあまり問題ないんだけど
そういうことを見ていると
ちゃんとプロセス見えてくるでしょうに
その場合は突然暴力ふるようになったということはないでしょう
だから 20 あるいは 16年
17 年間も見ていないんですね
自分の子供を 自分を殴られたところで
怪我したところで見るんですね
子供に殴られたと そこで答えが出る
ですから 我々は常に知恵の人間として過去を探るのではなくて
きちんとした因果関係を今の瞬間だけに絞って探す
追い知っておく その生き方だったら
一度も解決できない問題が出てこない
試してみてください 例えばもう馬鹿な母親が 16 年間もあるいは 17 年間も自分の子供のことを観察していないんだと
感情だけで 好みで 私の子だから可愛いんだと
面倒だけ見てあげればいいんだと言って
自分本位で 自分好みで
自分の楽しみで子供を買ってあげる
犬を飼っていることと同じことをやってますからね
そこで 18歳になったところで
その子はもう母親をぶん殴って怪我させたと
その場合はその時点だけ見ちゃう
そして 18歳の男の 男が年取っている体が弱い女の人を殴ったと
客観的に見るんです 冷血で言いさすにきりゃいいんです
何のこともない 例えば母親の名前は田中ふみよとするならば
田中ふみよという人が田中太郎という人に殴られたと
打っちゃえばいいんです
それだけ 問題解決します
でも我々ずるずる前書いたでしょうに
ちゃんとどうすればいいものとかね
感情とか それでずるずるむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃ
もやもやもやもやもや
やっぱりいくらなんで私の子供でしょうとかね
自分の子供に訴えるのは恥ずかしいんじゃないんで何言ってるんですかね
頭が悪いだけでしょうに
18歳  18歳ぐらいっていうのはものすごいものすごい男でしょうに
一人の手で自分の母親を殺すぐらいの力あるでしょうに
そういう人に殴られたら
その同じ家にいるわけにはいかんでしょうに
だからあまり遠く 頭所詮悪いんだから
あっちこっち考えるんじゃなくて
その場で問題を見て その場で出てくる答えがそれ
その その判断 この客観的な判断
それでも もしそういうケースがないことは祈りますけど
もしあったとするならば
やってみて答えが出る
これで終わります 例えば自分の子供が何か他の犯罪でも起こしたとする
自分にバレる だから国民として
一人の国民として自分に義務があるんです
犯罪なんかした人は隠れるのではなくて
警察に 言うという 報告すると
そこで自分の子供だから一緒に来いと
連れて行って この人はこういうこういうことをしました
どうぞ調べてください
で 任せて自分がお家に戻ればいいんです
で 子供はいろんな文句言うかもしれませんだけど
その子供の知恵が発達して欲しいんだから
それは子供をいじめることじゃないんです
そこで子供が「何でしょうかね
これは 母親のに 」と言ったら
いえ その場合は母親と子供の関係ではなくて
二人の人間のことだと
あなたは私の息子であることは
それはすごいプライベート
プライベートなことだと
でもあなたは日本人ですよ
私も一人の日本人です
だから権利は平等ですよと二人に
そこですごい知識的な答えでしょ
それぐらいのことを聞いて
その子供は勉強しないと思いますか？ですから
この このヤタッブータニャーナという
この これはもう究極的な答えなんです
知恵で知恵を持ってくるために
だからこの 四十年前のこととかね
一億年前でこうなったんだから
今私たちはこれで困っているとかね
どうでもいいことを何で考えるんですかね
おかしいこと 神様に我々は作られたんだと
この神様が裏切ったんだから
人間が今困っているんだと
だから答えがなくなっちゃうでしょう
今の人間の苦しみに だから答えを見つけるためには
我々は時間を全部逆戻りして
アダムとイブを見つかって
イブさんをもう包丁で刺さなくちゃいけないんですね
お前のせいだと だから馬鹿な話でしょう？だから今私の足が痛いんだったら
今治療するんであって
これは十年前のことやと思ったったら答えがなくなっちゃうんです
だから仏教は今の瞬間という言葉をすごく大事にするんです
そういう訓練なんですね
このヴィパッサナーという
そういうことでもやらせているのは
ジリジリと知恵が発達するはずなんですけど
私の話なんかあんたあっち行きなさいと言えるほど知恵が現れてくるはずなんですが
まあわかりませんですけど
あって隠して あって隠している可能性があります
[笑い]ですから この今の瞬間見ると
そこで原因も見えるし
結果も見えるし 結果が悪ければ次の瞬間で原因変えればいいんです
ですから 究極的な知恵の生き方には
このヤタッブータニャーナという言葉
如実知恵と言うんですが
如実に見る ありのままに見る
まああれは一般的な言葉です
ありのままに見る このありのままに見るということは
なかなか日本では理解されていないみたいところもあります
ある人がそこは質問してきたんで
このありのままに見ると言ったら
日本ではニュアンスが違うんだと
そのまま放っておけばいいという感じで
ありのままでいいんじゃないかと
これは素晴らしい教えだと
ありのまま そういう考え方ではないんです
厳しいんです 成り行きでいいじゃないという意味じゃないんですよ
ありのままっていうことはすごく鋭く見るということなんです
ですから この瞬間瞬間だけ見ていると
この原因と結果 原因と結果というものは見えてくる
そのプロセス そのプロセスというのは今の瞬間だけ正しくわかるんです
過去のことは正しくわかりません
もう忘れているんだから
例えばリンゴを一個取ったら
これ取った瞬間ではこの木のリンゴだとわかるでしょ
リンゴを取って箱に入れて家に運んだところで
このリンゴはどんな木のリンゴことわかりますかね
一本のリンゴしか持ってないんだったら
もうそれはわかりますけど
普通はリンゴを作っている人々にとってはもう 四十本とかね
五十本とか 百本とかリンゴの木ありますから
だからその人 我々人生もそういう人生だから
そこで木から取る瞬間で
このリンゴはこの木のリンゴだとわかりますよ
それまた箱 箱に入れて
トラックで家まで運ぶ
それからわからないんです
だからリンゴを持って
このリンゴはどんな木のリンゴでしょうねとかね
完全にバカバカらしいでしょう
だから過去というのははっきりわからないんです
はっきりしない だから放っておきましょう
同じく将来もそんなものですから
今の瞬間でどのように物事が起きているかということだけ
それだけ頭にあるならば
その人は究極的に幸せと幸福を見つかりますし
解決できない問題は一つもない
すごいこの早々 即座に解決法を見つかるんです
例えば私が例で言ったように
自分の十八歳の男の子が自分を殴ったらもう捕まって連れていけばいいんです
それでも行かないんだったら
もう電話かけたら警察が来るんです
その時私の息子が殴ったと言ったら間違いなんです
そうすると法律にならないんです
田中太郎が田中文雄を殴ったと言わないといけない
だからそれ一般的なもう常識のない
知恵のない人間がやる行動じゃない
でもそれ自体が知恵の行動なんです
だから知恵の行動っていうのはすごいなんか抜群で
もう大胆で どちらでもない
でもピッタシした答えなんですね
そういう風にそれできるのは
このヤタ・ブータ・ニャーナということを皆様にできれば
それは簡単です 過去を探らないで
将来にもう頭が動かさないで
今今今今起きている出来事だけやればいいんです
ですから 今日の朝 私の指がすごく強く深く切れちゃったんです
バンドエイドとかアルコール止めたら一つもないんです
部屋に で 私は事務所でもいっぱいあるのに
いつでも持って行った方が薬もあったんだけど
持って行った方が良かったのにと思ったんだけど
でももう過去でしょうね
今どうすればといえば
ティッシュありますからね
ティッシュ二枚持ってもう巻いておいたんですね
巻いても血が止まりません
これあれないんだから
貼るもうきちんと貼るやつは
でもいろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないんですね
じゃあ言ったらゴムバンド持ってきて
ゴムバンドでぴしぴしくせん縛って
それで終わったんですけど
そこで血も止まった でもこんな感じでティッシュ二枚くらい指に巻いて
ゴムバンドで巻いて これでこちらに来るのはちょっとかっこ悪いんですね
そこで考えたのは このこちらに来る途中で薬屋さんがいるんです
そちらのおじいちゃんがちょっとバセリンでも買おうとしたら
大体十五分二十分ぐらい喋るんです
飲み方とか全部教えてくれる
そこら辺はすごいそういう街だからね
そこで私は考えたのは
それぐらい年長あることだから
まあここら辺任せちゃえばいいんだと薬屋さんに
で行ったらそのおじいちゃんがいない
おばあちゃんがいたんですね
何のことはなく 指がこうなったんだけど
何とかしてくれませんかと
言ったら おばあちゃんが家の中から薬を持ってきて入れて
じゃあこうバンドエイドでも巻いてくれたんですね
それでこれちょっと緩いんですね
もうちょっと一枚上に巻きましょうと
言ったら そうですかと言ってもう一つつけてくれたんで
それでも緩かったんで
まあしょうがない それ以上はもう頼む必要ないと思って
この私のバンドでそのままそれ買ってきて
でもそれでも自分だから血がいっぱい出ましたけどね
こちら来てしっかり巻いておいて血が止まりましたけど
だからそれ何で言ったか
その瞬間 その瞬間の行動でいいということなの
私の行動はおかしいと誰かにいるんですか？指が切られて私はやった行動は
常識で なんでこのティッシュで巻いて
またゴムバンドで でもその場合ではそれしか答えがないんです
だからまあ途中で薬屋さんいるから
そこは途中でちゃんとしたバンド
かっこいいバンドだけど
まあ一応 だからもうそんなもんで
すごい簡単に我々にこのその瞬間で現れてくる問題は解決できる
で これ何に切れたかというと
ハサミに切れちゃったんです
だからそこで私を責めたら
ハサミでなんで切れるんですか？だとかどうかとかね
それももう過去だから考えません
ハサミの取り方が間違っただけで
切っちゃったんですね
それちょっと硬くて 硬いんだから強く切らなければと
前に指があった 後ろに切りたいものあったんだけど
指があって 切るだけで
ですから それに悩む必要とかね
自分を責める必要でも何でもないし
もう二度とやらなきゃいいんだから
やるかもしれないけど
ですから 解決できない問題っていうのはないということで
あのヤタ・ブータ・ニャーナ出すと
目実試験さえあれば 我々には正しい知恵が現れるんだということで
そうなるようにと頑張っていましょう
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]